this crypt have been around for a long
time I think Redford was hands on at one
point francois truffaut tried to make it
don't Houston tried to make it a lot of
filmmakers tried to lick it and they
couldn't I think probably because they
were faced with the same dilemma that
Tom was faced with how do we what do we
focus on what is that how do we get all
these genres right how do we respect
them and still have fun with them and
that's I think what
what's great he put his his two closest
friends in the movie Billy Crystal and
Chris cast and they hung out for the
most of the picture even though they
were mean Chris had a lot of scenes but
Billy only had a couple of seasons break
and I think that's a wonderful thing to
to come away really it mean fun that we
have I think really did translate onto
the screen 25 years later and I still
have kids sending email and attacking me
with swords and Toys R Us I mean it's
crazy the challenge is actually giving
the directory's vision because that's
what my job is it's to contribute and to
sometimes steer because some directors
don't understand makeup they know what
they want they don't actually know how
to achieve it and sometimes maybe you
can come up with an idea that they
haven't thought of or you know that kind
of thing but actually I look back and I
can see is standing in derbyshire
on the outskirts of Sheffield with this
fabulous rolling countryside before
and it was as though we were on a picnic
it's it was the feeling that you have
here today with all these people sitting
that's what it was like but we were
getting paid to turn up and work